完全にリンチ場みたいになってしまいましたが
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
すいません
病み上がりです
片頭痛で１日倒れていました
というわけで今日はですね
僕は今年おそらくこの体に摂取した飲み物の95%は炭酸水です
これで全部じゃないんですよ本当は
なんかウィルキンソン炭酸どれだけ飲んだか僕楽しみにしようと思ってて
今年からウィルキントンサン
ウィルキントンサン
今年からウィルキンソン炭酸飲んだの全部ゴミ袋に入れて
どれだけ飲んだか来年確かめようと思ったんですけど
それゴミと勘違いされてゴミに捨てられたんよ
誰かに
今回は多分大本命
半年以上
まじでウィルキンソン炭酸しか飲んでないから
炭酸水の味に関しては
すごい詳しいです
今回は割とガチな方ですよ
俺どれだけ飲んできたと思ってるのウィルキンソン炭酸
お茶にも目を振らず
水にも目を振らず
僕は一心不乱にウィルキンソン炭酸だけ飲み続けて
炭酸水中毒になり　貧血を起こし　一度倒れました
今回は面子がかかってる
炭酸水に関しては
本当に類まれに見る
すごい鋭さ
本当に今研ぎ澄まされてるので
炭酸水を当てていこうと思います
この半年間の僕の努力が試される今
まずはこの４種類何か紹介していきましょう
まずはこちら
セブンイレブンの炭酸水です
ま、たまに飲みますよ
ウィルキンソン炭酸が売ってない時たまに飲んでたんですけど
おえええええええ
何だろうね
美味しいですやっぱり
美味しいし
美味しいです
style oneなんでサークルKサンクスから出てる
炭酸水です
こっちはアサヒサントリー
ファミリーマートから出てる香る炭酸水です
コンビニでしか売ってない炭酸水を準備したんですけど
ファミマに関しては匂いのあるやつしかなかったのでこれはどうしようもなかったっす
これ多分香りだけなので鼻をつまめば多分普通の炭酸水だと思います
強い炭酸が魅力　１００年を超える伝説と信頼のブランドでございます
はいというわけでこの四種類でやっていきましょう
ひとまず味見です
４つの味をちょっと覚えます
あとはいつも親しみのある味をしっかり味を舌に覚えさせるのが大事です
いただきます
炭酸が強いからこれは多分いけると思います
次
セブンイレブンそのまま飲める炭酸水いきます
いただきます
stlye oneの炭酸水いきます
これ炭酸強くね？
いただきます
これはなんかあのあれだ
水と水の（ry
ファミリーマートの香る炭酸水
あっ匂いでわかる
けど匂いは嗅がずにいきましょう
匂いという観念は無しでやります
いただきます
え、甘いんだけど
なんで？
弟よ
ファミリーマートの香る炭酸水はジュースです
この時点で失格です　ありがとうございました
ちょっと確率が上がってしまったのですが
この３つで今回試していきたいと思います
紙コップカモン！
こちらの三種類で僕が味を当てていきます
同じくらいの量にしないとね
あっ
いただきます
スタイルワンではないな
ｄ
スタイルワンのあれではない気がします
セブンイレブン！
ED